lire courir et voir ce sont les trois
activités préférées des habitants d'île
de france c'est en tout cas ce que
révèle un sondage fresque réalisée à la
demande du journal du dimanche
un sondage qui fournit quelques chiffres
étonnants 51% des personnes interrogées
avouent regarder la télévision en guise
de loisirs 30% déclarent s'adonner à la
lecture et 8% au pmu le détail de ces
chiffres avec jacky galy laurent sablic
qui ont également voulu vérifier les
résultats de cette enquête auprès de
quelques parisiens furent dépensés pour
la culture
que font les habitants de notre belle
région quand il ne travaille pas plus de
la moitié s'installe devant les étranges
lucarnes une grosse minorité se consacre
aux joies de la vie de famille
près d'un tiers ouvre un livre ou un
journal derrière ces stars des loisirs
on trouve le sport la sortie au cinéma
ou le jardinage au général j'y pense
j'ai achevé soit cinéma français
6h30 axe est ce point citer un nom
d'acteur de cinéma
actuellement seulement due à l'aigreur
de théâtre
un acteur l'argent vois pas tellement
qui vous proposait d'échanger un livre
contre une place de cinéma vous seriez
d'accord merci je vous échangez votre
livre contre un ticket de cinéma vous
seriez d'accord
non je perdrais 4 up
si on en croit ce sondage de paris à
sucy en brie
il n'y a guère d'analphabètes en effet
55% des sondés lisent un livre ou plus
par mois 28% se contente d'un à quatre
livres par an il n'en reste que 16 %
pour avouer leur abstinence totale à
l'égard de la lecture vous une idée de
combien vous dépensez par mois au plus
et je sais pas grand chose tant suivez
tous les livres à l'oeil
combien vous dépensez par mois pour
votre culture musique théâtre cinéma
d'environ 1000 francs
ces bases j'ai de l'argent eu lui prend
3400 je passe de 130 emprunt c'est pas
moins de 100 francs
tu fais partie ce moment
les journaux de temps en temps et puis
une fois par mois au cinéma lire aller
au concert visiter une exposition c'est
rarement gratuit pour 4 % de notre
échantillon ce n'est bien un problème
puisque ces boulimiques des loisirs y
consacrent plus de 1000 francs par mois
à l'autre bout de l'échelle la moitié
environ des sondés ne peut ou ne veut
dépenser que 100 à 300 front pour ses
sorties et combien d'argent ou consacré
par mois votre culture
malgré ces défis sélectionnés parce que
nous ne sommes pas les parisiens
le som décoration et
c'est pas une excuse non pas du tout
mais enfin on a moins de possibilité
qu'à paris